hi i'm bandy i'm the partnerships
director at glamour uk
and the treatment i'll be trying is
microblading on my eyebrows by
suman how does it feel
it hurts my passion for eyebrows started
when my mother had chemotherapy and i
knew how much it meant to having
confidence again so i really wanted to
learn
semi-permanent and ever since then it's
been my forte
obviously worried about potential pain
so that's in the back of my
head as well we use a strong numbing
cream which we apply it and it takes
away the sensation
only thing is you hear the scratching
noise of the bleeding is where i tell
them to bring headphones but other than
that it's quite a comfortable procedure
i think my biggest nightmare is for it
to go wrong and to have wonky
eyebrows at the end if you don't like
your results and you're unhappy with it
which is very rare
then the best is not to have your
retouch appointment if it still doesn't
fade away
then you come and have a removal session
like most people i have my
insecure days but overall i wouldn't say
i feel necessarily
pressure boys that will strive to be
clever and funny and interesting
and looks have always been like a
secondary currency we don't have black
doesn't exist in tattoo
in my experience darker skin tones and
oily skin do bleed a lot
so they're the ones that fade much
quicker and it just means they need more
of a retouch
if you're not naturally embracing how
you look
then you're superficial and you're empty
and you know why are you trying to
change yourself so the whole thing about
inclusivity is everybody should be able
to do what they want right
their skin is open now i'm going to
insert the ink
you might feel stinging which is
absolutely normal okay okay
be prepared for a little bit of
discomfort it's not an easy plain
sailing thing there's a little bit of
discomfort is what i'd say
it's fine needle it spits out like
little pixelated dots
that's why you don't feel it i'm lightly
just going over the first
layer of the surface the procedure takes
up to two hours
um numbing and measuring takes the
longest the treatment cost is from 500
of a different artist and myself is 600
it can go to 650 depending on
whether you want the shading added to it
ombre
brows and there's also a diamond eyebrow
how does it feel it hurts
it's quite tender yeah so yeah
after 10 days you'll find the final
results it's all healed and you'll get
your color results and the shape
revealed wow
they look pretty incredible i'm really
pleased with them
really pleased yeah i've got the
boldness and the definition that i
wanted
so this is the final result um i'm
really pleased with it
it's in the healing phase now so it's
not quite where it needs to be
i would definitely recommend it to a
friend if i know that they're a bit of a
beauty junkie like me my brows naturally
don't look
identical and that's always bothered me
and this has given me that illusion at
least so
really pleased